les athlètes féminines sont soumises à
des tests de féminité jusqu'au pradal ya
eu des hommes homosexuels se sont
glissés dans les athlètes féminines pas
glisser entre guillemets enfin pour
récolter des médailles
donc maintenant il ya les tests de
féminité et nous on fait un sujet sur le
procédé revenait je vous explique à la
bourde de secondes un nouveau révélateur
qui indique à chantonnay mans le taux
d'ozone pas que vous avez vous alors
vous mettez simplement face on va le
faire
06 11 ans
j'étais au courant de ces tests est est
ce que vous sentez en vous une part de
masculinité est ou non nous sont
féminines
j'ai peut-être été minime que vous êtes
attirés sexuellement par les femmes du
tout c'était numéro 6 on dit ça nous
avait été opéré des oreilles ah non là
c'est pour les enfants malades
là c'est bien 70 c'est vous c'est très
drôle de truc c où je sais pas d'où vous
sentez-vous ces trucs vous le sentez de
tentes et on attend certaines preuves
je voudrais bien oui mais il ya un petit
peu de monde
ok vous inquiétez pas il y en a pour
juste quelques secondes 1 vous dire tout
de suite le résultat vous êtes 612 il ya
un problème
vous avez été opéré ah oui c'est très
net là y'a comme un temps là comme un
temps vous êtes opéré j'ai été opéré oui
les domaines temps
il ya trois ans il n'y a aucun phénomène
de rejet tout va bien vous la mise ou la
pâte ici parce que la série bones pour
les équipes masculines alors oui vous
êtes bonne que pour ça parce que là je
vous trouve plus bonne du tout
maintenant la c6 et vous madame on vient
de faire la photo je dis rien 15 témoins
pouvez pas nier que vous êtes monté
comme un âne alors on va vous dire à
cette année mais quelle est votre part
de masculinité elle est énorme et
volailles
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu